là jean françois besson bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous un petit mot
rapidement on a parlé du prélèvement à
la source a été validé la semaine
dernière par le gouvernement pour les
frontaliers ça se passe comment ça
change pas grand chose si ce n'est que
l'employeur étant en suisse évidemment
le fisc français ne peut pas lui
demander de prélever l'impôt et donc
pour les travailleurs frontaliers qui
exercent dans le canton de neuchâtel ou
de vaud pour notre région mais bien
simplement il ya le fisc va venir
prélevée directement sur leur compte
s'ils ont donné leur rib lors de leur
déclaration
le l'impôt qu'ils devront honorer tous
les mois en gros c'est une
mensualisation alisation une très bonne
nouvelle pour les frontaliers notamment
pour les chômeurs frontaliers
ils vont être considéré en gros comme
des suisses pour un retour à l'emploi
alors expliquez nous parce que c'est
tout nouveau pour les gens justement qui
cherchent un emploi les travailleurs
frontaliers
oui alors pour comprendre il faut
revenir en 2014 en 2014 le peuple suisse
dans une votation dont ils ont
l'habitude a voté pour
contre l'immigration de masse l'idée
c'était de limiter l'immigration et le
pardon la confédération s'est trouvé
devant un gros problème
comment faire pour limiter l'arrivée
l'étranger tout en gardant les relations
avec l'union européenne et en
particulier la libre circulation des
personnes
c'est la fameuse préférence indigène
c'est comme ça mais lights donc ils ont
mis trois ans pour arriver à trouver à
faire le grand écart finalement entre
ces deux oppositions et depuis le 1er
juillet de cette année à les mises en
application ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que toute entreprise qui embauche
doigt sur les secteurs qui sont en
tension doit faire passer ces offres
d'emploi par les eaux et rhdp donc
l'équivalent de pôle emploi du canton et
pendant cinq 5 jours cette offre
d'emploi et garder uniquement au niveau
de l'eau et donc ça c'est pour les
suisses mais là la nouveauté c'est que
si on a déjà travaillé en suisse on peut
s'inscrire sur ce site et on est site
considéré comme un suisse en fait voilà
on s'est battu pour justement
avoir savoir d'abord quelle était la
position de la suisse par rapport aux
travailleurs frontaliers et enfin on a
une réponse au niveau de la
confédération donc du seco qui précise
que le travailleur frontalier doit être
intégré exactement comme un indigène
puisque c'est la terminologie employée
et donc il a les mêmes droits
non et dans l'accompagnement de peu sa
recherche d'emploi
il reste 30 secondes ce qui est très
important pour les gens qui nous
écoutent s'ils sont justement dans ce
cas là c'est qu'il faut s'inscrire pour
ça justement vous leur filer un petit
coup de pouce voilà alors s'ils ont plus
d'un il faut avoir travaillé plus d'un
en suisse qui sont licenciés en suisse
surtout qu'ils n'hésitent pas à aller
s'inscrire auprès des rp il faut bien
sûr qu'ils avaient aussi à pôle emploi
mais qu'ils aillent s'inscrire dans leur
erp est due à du canton et là ils
devront être accompagnés pour leur
recherche d'emploi sur suisse et bien
c'est parfait merci beaucoup d'avoir été
notre invité ce soir pour nous expliquer
tout ça